la paz total en Colombia está un poco
más lejos tras el anuncio del fin del
cese al fuego con el grupo criminal más
grande del país el clan del Golfo
he ordenado a la fuerza pública
reactivar todas las operaciones
militares contra el clan del Golfo se
suspende el cese bilateral con este
grupo al margen de la ley no
permitiremos que sigan sembrando zozobra
y terror en las comunidades la razón un
supuesto ataque con fusil del grupo
criminal contra la policía Aunque el fin
de La tregua comenzó antes en la región
del bajo cauca en el Noroeste del país
que vive un paro minero desde el 2 de
marzo presuntamente instigado por el
clan del Golfo para beneficiarse de las
rutas de narcotráfico según acusa el
gobierno colombiano tras el anuncio la
organización ilegal no tardó en
responder e incendió varios vehículos en
la región o como advertencia
situaciones como las ocurridas el día de
hoy en la que vehículos por fuera de
caravanas fueron incendiados
no pueden repetirse rechazamos
con toda contundencia los actos de
violencia que se han venido presentando
en el bajo cauca antioqueño
fundamentalmente el ejecutivo ya había
acusado al clan del Golfo por no
respetar el armisticio y seguir
Traficando con cocaína y oro en la
región este movimiento es además una
advertencia para los otros dos grupos
con los que el gobierno está negociando
la paz el eln y las disidencias de las
farcp y el mensaje es claro cualquier
conversación de paz puede quebrarse si
no se respetan a sus términos